hi there day 54 I believe geez
slowly the I'm you know getting towards
the end of this I tell you there are
days like today where if I didn't have
the challenge I probably wouldn't have
done anything but I spent a good an hour
and a half or so reading the transcript
of Kim Young has podcast on my iPad
since I've gone through and saved all
the words now it's hard there's lots of
stuff I don't understand Stan there's
lots of words that I can't even get a
definition from the dictionary for but I
kind of understand it and every time I
read it I understand a bit more and when
I listen and it kind of reminded me that
you know some people can't deal with the
fact that they don't understand to me I
think not understanding is a condition
of language learning there's always
things that I don't understand
there's always whole sentences that I
don't understand there's individual
words that I don't understand there's
forms of the language why is it this
form instead of that form that I don't
understand and I that doesn't bother me
I just proceed reading getting what I
can out of it interpreting it my way
exposing myself to the language because
I have the experience I know that
eventually it will become clear but a
lot of people and we see this on our
format linked like what does this word
mean this particular word and there's no
fast about those things and in a way all
the time we spend at least my way of
learning is the time that I spent trying
to nail those things down it's time that
I could be spent
it could be spending absorbing more and
more of the language so I think it's
important to accept the fact that
there's always things that we don't
understand justice we will always not
always but we we learn from making
mistakes I believe we also learned from
working with material where we don't
understand and it shouldn't bother us I
think people want things nailed down too
much someone asked me here on my youtube
channel you know I'm learning French but
do you think French is a useful language
I mean I've learned I'm learning Korean
how useful is Korean now what's your
definition of useful
learn Chinese because it's useful I'm
not sure it will be useful despite all
the hype however
Chinese is a fascinating language
fascinating culture guarantee you'll
have lots of rich encounters with with
Chinese people with Chinese culture and
so forth useful unless you're doing
business in China probably not so useful
same way with French you may end up
doing business in a french-speaking
country but more than that French you
can access the literature you can travel
and enjoy France so every language is
useful I never questioned you know is
this more useful than that I don't know
check was useful when I visited the
Czech Republic Romanian was useful when
I was in Romania so anyway I will
continue now you know if I didn't have
to do these videos every day and wait
for them to load up I'd have another 15
20 minutes to spend on my Korean
learning but I will continue doing these
until the end of the 90 day challenge I
hope you guys are all working